dawn on another California morning and a
new fire threatens another neighborhood
this time the flames roaring through the
hillsides northwest of Los Angeles the
Ronald Reagan Presidential Library among
the buildings at risk dry-brush
providing the fuel and icy gale force
winds driving the flames on the
evacuation orders covered an area
including a number of ranches staff
trying to wrangle horses to safety as
the smoke closed in just after 6:00 a.m.
we had a fire start at Easy Street
Madera unfortunately it was about the
worst time it could happen 40 mile an
hour sustained winds and again fuels
that were ripe and ready to carry fire
we had incredible robust quick response
from our neighbors to the south of LA
city in LA County and your firefighters
throughout Southern California have now
responded in to Ventura County they are
actively engaged in protecting
structures significant evacuations and
the fire is still moving pretty quickly
the sky for miles around gray with that
choking smoke
they've been predicting this for days
but this historic wind Ament as they
describe it has now arrived and with
wind gusts up to 80 miles per hour there
is almost nothing firefighters can do to
contain the flames all they can do is
try to keep people out of the way
they've been through this often enough
to know the drill those evacuated from
their homes taking shelter their pets
coming to however familiar this might be
now to people living here it is still an
unnerving time you can't take any
chances it we learned that last year
with the other fires and it could move
so quickly and and trap you so we did
what we could and got what we could
valuables and now we're here
you can't wait it out you just can't sit
there and say well I'm gonna see if this
goes away but it's real it is scary
we've seen so many fires and they jump
they leap you just don't know where it's
gonna end up so I started seeing
embers flying at my house and then
elsewhere in the state firefighters
continue to make progress on the fire
that's consumed tens of thousands of
acres of wine country hundreds of
thousands of people are without power as
a precautionary measure to prevent power
lines starting more fires the strong
winds are forecast to last into tomorrow
with them the potential for fires to
spread California's wildfire season has
exploded into life Gregg Milam Sky News
Simi Valley in California